bentornato a capire l'informazione e il calcolo quantistico, mi chiamo John Matus e sono il direttore tecnico per l'educazione presso IBM
Quantum. Questa è la 12ª lezione della serie ed è l'ultima lezione della terza unità, che riguarda la formulazione generale
dell'informazione quantistica. Questa lezione è incentrata su una nozione fondamentale nell'informazione quantistica, che è quella della
purificazione di uno stato quantistico. Una purificazione di uno stato quantistico rappresentato da una matrice densità è
uno stato puro di un sistema composto più grande che ci lascia con lo stato originale quando il resto del sistema composto viene
eliminato o tracciato via. Ogni matrice densità ha una purificazione e possiamo imparare molto
sugli stati quantistici e sull'informazione quantistica in generale studiando le purificazioni. A un livello intuitivo,
i vettori di stato quantistico che rappresentano stati puri sono oggetti matematici più semplici delle matrici densità e, pensando alle
purificazioni degli stati, possiamo vedere stati quantistici arbitrari dei sistemi come semplici parti di qualcosa di più grande ma
più semplice. Parleremo anche della fedeltà tra due stati quantistici, che è un valore che quantifica la loro
somiglianza o sovrapposizione, ed è spesso usata come metodo per misurare quanto sia buono un determinato stato rispetto a
uno stato ideale. In particolare, discuteremo la definizione di fedeltà insieme ad alcune sue proprietà di base e vedremo
come la fedeltà si collega alle purificazioni. Ecco una panoramica della lezione: inizieremo con le purificazioni, inclusa la
definizione e una semplice dimostrazione della loro esistenza, che ci dice come trovarne una quando ne abbiamo bisogno. Poi discuteremo qualcosa noto
come la decomposizione di Schmidt di un vettore di stato quantistico di due sistemi, e vedremo come le decomposizioni di Schmidt si relazionano alle
purificazioni. Discuteremo poi una relazione di fondamentale importanza tra due qualsiasi purificazioni dello stesso stato, nota come equivalenza unitaria
delle purificazioni, e infine analizzeremo alcuni esempi. Passeremo poi alla fedeltà,
inclusa la sua definizione e alcune proprietà di base. Parleremo del lemma della misurazione gentile, che è un fatto molto
utile che collega la fedeltà alle misurazioni, e infine, per concludere la lezione, passeremo al teorema di Uhlmann, che
stabilisce una connessione fondamentale tra fedeltà e purificazioni. Iniziamo con la
definizione di purificazione. Una purificazione di uno stato, che si assume sia rappresentato da una matrice
densità, è uno stato puro di un sistema composto più grande che lascia lo stato originale da cui siamo partiti quando il resto
del sistema composto viene tracciato via. Possiamo esprimere questo in modo più preciso in termini matematici come
segue: se abbiamo un sistema X che si trova in qualche stato ρ, il che significa che ρ è una matrice densità che rappresenta uno stato di X,
e s è un vettore di stato quantistico di una coppia di sistemi XY tale che, tracciando via Y dallo stato puro ψ bra ψ,
si ottiene ρ, allora diciamo che s è una purificazione di ρ. Naturalmente i nomi non hanno importanza: possiamo
nominare i nostri sistemi e i nostri stati come vogliamo, e anche l'ordine dei sistemi non ha importanza. Per esempio,
se il sistema Y fosse a sinistra invece che a destra, ma tutto il resto fosse uguale, chiameremmo comunque ψ una purificazione di ρ. Ma
per il resto della lezione ci atterremo principalmente a questa configurazione, per semplicità. La prima cosa da dire
riguardo alla definizione è che le purificazioni esistono sempre per ogni matrice densità ρ. Per essere più precisi, ogni matrice
densità ρ ha una purificazione come quella descritta nella definizione, a condizione che il sistema Y sia almeno grande quanto X, il che
significa che Y ha almeno tanti stati classici quanti ne ha X. La nozione di purificazione e
il fatto che le purificazioni esistano sempre si rivelano di fondamentale importanza e fanno parte di ciò che rende l'informazione quantistica bella. Spero di riuscire a
convincerti di questo fatto entro la fine della lezione. Ora dimostriamo che ogni matrice densità ha una purificazione, e nel
processo vedremo come ottenerne una quando ne abbiamo bisogno. Proprio come nella definizione,
supponiamo che X sia un sistema e che ρ sia una matrice densità che rappresenta uno stato di
X. Consideriamo ora una qualsiasi espressione di ρ come combinazione convessa di stati puri, come scritta sullo schermo. In parole,
per una certa scelta di un intero positivo n, abbiamo un vettore di probabilità p₀ fino a pₙ₋₁, nonché vettori di stato
quantistico ψ₀ fino a ψₙ₋₁, e facendo la media degli stati puri corrispondenti ponderati per le probabilità
otteniamo ρ. Per esempio, potremmo usare il teorema spettrale per ottenere un'espressione di ρ come questa, e se lo facessimo
potremmo prendere n come il numero di stati classici di X. In realtà potremmo prendere n come il rango di ρ, che è
uguale al numero di autovalori non nulli di ρ, contando ognuno un numero di volte pari alla sua molteplicità, e
questo non è mai maggiore del numero di stati classici di X, ma potrebbe essere più piccolo. D'altra parte, questa non deve
necessariamente essere una decomposizione spettrale di ρ e non abbiamo bisogno che questi vettori di stato quantistico siano ortogonali. Per esempio, qualsiasi espressione di ρ come questa
va bene, ed ecco una purificazione di ρ. La somma copre gli stessi valori
della nostra espressione di ρ e all'interno della somma prendiamo le radici quadrate delle probabilità moltiplicate per ψₐ in prodotto tensoriale
con |k⟩ₐ. Qui tra l'altro stiamo assumendo che 0 fino a n meno uno siano stati classici del secondo sistema Y, quindi
ha senso che s sia un vettore di stato quantistico della coppia XY come nella definizione. Non è effettivamente importante
qui che usiamo gli stati della base standard di Y in questa espressione. Potresti sostituire qualsiasi collezione ortonormale di
stati al posto di |k⟩₀ fino a |k⟩ₙ₋₁ se lo desiderassi, e ora possiamo verificare che questa è effettivamente
una purificazione calcolando la traccia parziale su Y. Ecco un'espressione dello stato che otteniamo eseguendo la traccia parziale:
la traccia di |k⟩ₐ⟨k|ᵦ è uno o zero a seconda che a sia uguale a b oppure no, e quindi l'espressione
si semplifica nella nostra espressione originale di ρ, ed è così semplice. Quindi è molto facile ottenere una
purificazione, purché abbiamo abbastanza stati classici di Y o, in alternativa, un insieme ortonormale abbastanza grande da usare al
posto degli stati della base standard |k⟩₀ fino a |k⟩ₙ₋₁. Tra l'altro, se il numero di
stati classici di Y è più piccolo del rango di ρ, allora non esisterà una purificazione, e lascio questo
da meditare, se scegli di farlo. Ecco un esempio: consideriamo
la matrice densità che abbiamo visto più volte nella lezione sulle matrici densità. Qui abbiamo un'espressione di questa
matrice densità come combinazione convessa di stati puri. Non è una decomposizione spettrale, ma non ci
interessa, e con praticamente nessuno sforzo possiamo scrivere una purificazione dello stato seguendo la
ricetta. Quella non è l'unica purificazione di questa matrice densità: le purificazioni non sono uniche, ma non c'è problema.
La definizione non dice nulla sull'unicità e, in realtà, esiste una relazione molto interessante tra diverse purificazioni dello stesso stato, ma
ne parleremo un po' più avanti nella lezione. Considereremo poi le decomposizioni di Schmidt, che sono espressioni di
vettori di stato quantistico bipartiti in una certa forma che descriverò tra poco. Prendono il nome da Erhard
Schmidt, lo stesso Schmidt noto per la procedura di ortogonalizzazione di Gram-Schmidt, ma nel caso delle decomposizioni di Schmidt probabilmente non dovrebbero
essere attribuite a Schmidt: è in realtà matematicamente equivalente a qualcosa chiamato decomposizione ai valori singolari per le matrici, che è qualcosa che è stato
riscoperto più volte, ma queste cose a volte accadono. In ogni caso, ecco cosa intendiamo
quando ci riferiamo a una decomposizione di Schmidt: per una scelta arbitraria di un vettore di stato quantistico s per una coppia di
sistemi XY, è sempre possibile scrivere s in una forma speciale. Quella forma è come
quella mostrata qui sullo schermo, dove R è un intero positivo, p₀ fino a pᵣ₋₁ sono numeri reali positivi che
insieme formano un vettore di probabilità, x₀ fino a xᵣ₋₁ sono vettori unitari corrispondenti al sistema X, e y₀
fino a yᵣ₋₁ sono vettori unitari corrispondenti al sistema Y. Ora, questo potrebbe non sembrare particolarmente
speciale finché non ti dico che entrambi gli insiemi x₀ fino a xᵣ₋₁ e y₀ fino a yᵣ₋₁ devono essere
ortonormali. Quindi perché è speciale? Beh, se scegliessimo una base qualsiasi per uno dei due sistemi, diciamo
i vettori X corrispondenti al sistema X, potremmo sempre esprimere s in questa forma, e questo ci costringerebbe a
scegliere i vettori Y in un modo particolare. In realtà lo facciamo abbastanza spesso, come facciamo con la base standard quando ci
prepariamo ad analizzare una misurazione nella base standard. Ma in generale, anche se scegliamo una base ortonormale per i vettori X,
i vettori Y che otteniamo non saranno necessariamente ortonormali. Analogamente, se scegliessimo una
base ortonormale per i vettori Y e provassimo a esprimere s in questa forma di nuovo, ci riusciresti, ma di nuovo i vettori X non sarebbero
necessariamente ortonormali. Infine, se scegliessimo vettori ortonormali per entrambi i sistemi e
provassi ad esprimere s in una forma come questa, non funzionerebbe necessariamente perché potresti trovarti ad aver bisogno di qualche termine incrociato, ma c'è solo un
indice in questa somma, che è a. Quindi la forma è speciale, ma è sempre possibile
scrivere un vettore unitario s dato in questo modo. Ecco come puoi farlo: prima calcola una decomposizione spettrale
per lo stato ridotto di uno dei due sistemi. Non importa quale, ma per descrivere come si fa, guardiamo lo stato ridotto di
X, quindi stiamo tracciando via Y. Ciò significa che p₀ fino a pᵣ₋₁ sono gli autovalori
di questo stato ridotto ρ e x₀ fino a xᵣ₋₁ sono autovettori unitari corrispondenti a questi autovalori. Tra l'altro,
l'assunzione qui è che ignoriamo i termini per i quali gli autovalori sono zero, perché quei termini non contribuiscono nulla alla
somma. Vale a dire che p₀ fino a pᵣ₋₁ sono tutti numeri reali positivi e R è il numero di autovalori non nulli
contando le molteplicità, che è uguale al rango di ρ. Quindi abbiamo p₀ fino a pᵣ₋₁
nonché x₀ fino a xᵣ₋₁, e tutto ciò che resta è trovare i vettori y₀ fino a yᵣ₋₁.
C'è una sola scelta che può funzionare: quei vettori sono determinati in modo univoco a questo punto e possono
essere facilmente trovati usando la semplice formula mostrata sullo schermo. E ciò che è sorprendente è che
se definiamo questi vettori in questo modo, allora è garantito che siano ortonormali, e questo ci dà una decomposizione di Schmidt. Non lo dimostrerò in questo
video, ma non è troppo difficile e puoi consultare il materiale scritto per la lezione nel caso fossi interessato. Controlla
la descrizione del video per un link, come al solito. Come esempio, consideriamo questo
vettore di stato quantistico, che abbiamo ottenuto come purificazione dell'esempio di matrice densità a cui continuiamo a tornare.
Non è una decomposizione di Schmidt perché gli stati zero e più non sono ortonormali, ma possiamo trovarne una
usando la procedura che ho appena descritto. Il primo passo è calcolare una decomposizione spettrale per lo stato ridotto
di X, che è lo stesso esempio di matrice densità, ed ecco una decomposizione spettrale di essa, che abbiamo visto
nella lezione 9. Quindi scegliamo p₀, P₁, x₀ e X₁ come
mostrato sullo schermo. p₀ e P₁ sono gli autovalori di ρ e x₀ e X₁ sono
gli autovettori unitari corrispondenti. Resta quindi da calcolare y₀ e y₁, e se lo facciamo otteniamo |+⟩
per y₀ e -1 × |−⟩ per y₁. Non è immediato: devi
effettivamente fare il calcolo per vederlo, ma è quello che otteniamo, e come atteso quei due vettori sono ortonormali,
come saranno sempre se hai eseguito i calcoli correttamente. E questo ci dà una decomposizione di Schmidt.
Le decomposizioni di Schmidt sono molto utili in molte situazioni e tra poco vedremo cosa ci dicono
sulle purificazioni. Le purificazioni non sono uniche: un dato stato quantistico rappresentato
da una matrice densità avrà di fatto infinite purificazioni. Esiste tuttavia una stretta
relazione che vale sempre tra due qualsiasi purificazioni dello stesso stato, talvolta chiamata equivalenza unitaria
delle purificazioni. Ecco come funziona: sia ρ una matrice densità
che rappresenta uno stato quantistico di un sistema X, e supponiamo di avere due purificazioni qualsiasi di quello stato che siano
stati puri dello stesso sistema composto. Per concretezza, supponiamo che s e φ
siano vettori di stato quantistico di una coppia di sistemi XY che ci danno entrambi ρ quando il sistema Y viene tracciato
via. Ciò che dice l'equivalenza unitaria delle purificazioni è che deve esistere un'operazione unitaria U che agisce solo sul
sistema Y e trasforma s in φ. In altre parole, sebbene queste siano
purificazioni arbitrarie di ρ e non assumiamo nulla su di esse tranne che entrambe purificano ρ e sono
entrambe stati dello stesso sistema composto XY, devono essere equivalenti in qualche senso, a meno di un'operazione unitaria su Y
soltanto. Vedremo alcuni esempi che illustrano perché questo è interessante e quali implicazioni ha, ma prima
vediamo perché è vero. Iniziamo con una decomposizione spettrale di ρ, che è la
matrice densità che sia s che φ purificano. E proprio come quando abbiamo discusso la decomposizione di Schmidt,
assumeremo di aver eliminato tutti i termini corrispondenti ad autovalori nulli. Quindi p₀ fino a pᵣ₋₁
sono tutti numeri reali positivi, x₀ fino a xᵣ₋₁ sono autovettori ortonormali di ρ, e R è per caso
il rango di ρ. Tra l'altro, come osservazione a margine, nota quanto spesso stiamo ricorrendo al teorema spettrale a questo punto:
è uno strumento incredibilmente utile e, in effetti, senza di esso saremmo perduti. In ogni caso, ora che abbiamo una decomposizione
spettrale di ρ, possiamo calcolare le decomposizioni di Schmidt dei nostri due vettori, proprio come prima, e saranno
quasi esattamente le stesse. I coefficienti e i vettori X sono gli stessi perché provengono dalla decomposizione spettrale dello stato ridotto, che
è la stessa per entrambi i vettori. L'unica differenza è che potremmo ottenere vettori diversi per il secondo sistema. Per
il primo vettore, che è s, otterremo un insieme di vettori y₀ fino a yᵣ₋₁, e per il secondo vettore, che è φ, otterremo
una raccolta possibilmente diversa che possiamo chiamare z₀ fino a zᵣ₋₁. Ora abbiamo quindi le decomposizioni di Schmidt
per i nostri due vettori, che sembrano molto simili tranne per il fatto che i vettori per il secondo sistema potrebbero essere diversi. Ma queste
sono decomposizioni di Schmidt, quindi queste due collezioni sono entrambe ortonormali, e possiamo semplicemente scegliere
una matrice unitaria U che manda yₐ in zₐ per ogni a. Puoi sempre farlo: le operazioni
unitarie sono in effetti equivalenti a mappe lineari che trasformano una base ortonormale in un'altra, e se
questi due insiemi non dovessero per caso coprire l'intero spazio corrispondente a Y, possiamo sempre estenderli entrambi a basi
ortonormali usando, non a caso, la procedura di ortogonalizzazione di Gram-Schmidt. Ed è così che viene dimostrata l'equivalenza
unitaria delle purificazioni. Nella lezione 4 della serie abbiamo discusso il protocollo di codifica superdensa,
che consente a un mittente di trasmettere due bit classici a un ricevitore inviando un qubit al costo di un ebit di
entanglement condiviso. Quindi assumo che tu abbia già familiarità con quel protocollo, e il punto di questo esempio è
spiegare brevemente come si collega all'equivalenza unitaria delle purificazioni. Ricorda che il modo in cui
il protocollo funziona è che Alice e Bob condividono un ebit, ovvero uno stato di Bell φ⁺. Alice sceglie di trasformare quello
stato di Bell in uno qualsiasi dei quattro stati di Bell a seconda dei due bit che vuole inviare, e poi manda il suo
qubit a Bob, che misura per vedere quale stato di Bell ha. Nota che tutti e quattro gli stati di Bell
ci danno lo stesso stato ridotto per il qubit di Bob, che è lo stato completamente misto, e in effetti questo è già sufficiente
per concludere che la codifica superdensa è possibile. Tutti e quattro gli stati di Bell purificano lo stato completamente misto, quindi per l'equivalenza unitaria
delle purificazioni sappiamo che deve essere possibile per Alice trasformare lo stato di Bell φ⁺ in uno
degli altri applicando una qualche operazione unitaria al suo qubit. Naturalmente non è difficile trovare operazioni unitarie che
funzionino davvero, e sono molto semplici, ma è comunque interessante che possiamo raggiungere la conclusione che questo è
possibile senza nemmeno pensare alle operazioni unitarie stesse. Inoltre possiamo concludere
che le generalizzazioni della codifica superdensa a sistemi più grandi sono possibili, purché abbiamo un modo di generalizzare gli stati di Bell a sistemi più grandi
in modo che diano tutti lo stato completamente misto come stato ridotto di Bob. In effetti esistono diversi modi noti per farlo.
Un contesto diverso in cui l'equivalenza unitaria delle purificazioni ha implicazioni è la crittografia
quantistica. Una delle sue implicazioni più importanti è che esclude l'esistenza di un protocollo quantistico incondizionatamente sicuro per una
primitiva crittografica nota come impegno di bit. Quindi cos'è l'impegno di bit? L'impegno di bit è un esempio
di primitiva crittografica, con cui intendiamo un compito o una procedura di basso livello che fornisce alcune funzionalità di base,
che possono poi essere usate come blocco costruttivo per fare cose più interessanti, come creare schemi di firma digitale o costruire
protocolli a conoscenza zero. Nel caso dell'impegno di bit, la funzionalità di base è che un giocatore,
Alice, è in grado di impegnarsi su un valore binario di sua scelta con un secondo giocatore, Bob, ma la sua scelta rimane nascosta
finché non decide di rivelarla. Richiediamo due proprietà specifiche a un protocollo che implementa l'impegno di
bit: deve essere vincolante, il che significa che Alice non può cambiare idea una volta che si è impegnata su un bit, e
deve essere occultante, il che significa che Bob non può determinare il bit di Alice finché lei non sceglie di rivelarlo.
Sarebbe quindi molto bello poter implementare questa primitiva usando l'informazione quantistica, perché è una
primitiva utile, ma senza ulteriori assunzioni risulta impossibile farlo perfettamente con l'informazione quantistica, o anche solo
approssimativamente, e l'equivalenza unitaria delle purificazioni rivela come questo, a un livello molto alto. L'idea è
che se esistesse un protocollo quantistico per l'impegno di bit, dovrebbe esserci una cosiddetta versione purificata di quel protocollo, dove possiamo immaginare che
Alice abbia un sistema A, Bob abbia un sistema B, e dopo che l'impegno è stato fatto ma prima che Alice riveli, la coppia AB si trova in
uno di due stati puri ψ₀ o ψ₁ a seconda del bit su cui Alice si
impegna. Se il protocollo è perfettamente occultante, allora deve essere che Bob non riesce a distinguere tra le due
possibilità di impegno, quindi il suo stato ridotto deve essere lo stesso per le due possibilità. Tuttavia, questo implica, per
l'equivalenza unitaria delle purificazioni, che Alice possa trasformare l'uno nell'altro applicando una qualche operazione unitaria
ad A soltanto. Quindi il protocollo ha completamente fallito nell'essere vincolante. Ci sono dei dettagli che ho
sorvolato, ma il cuore della questione è che l'equivalenza unitaria delle purificazioni ci dice che questa primitiva non è qualcosa
che possiamo implementare in modo affidabile usando l'informazione quantistica senza ulteriori assunzioni di qualche
tipo. L'ultimo esempio di un'implicazione dell'equivalenza unitaria delle purificazioni è un teorema noto come
teorema di Hughston-Jozsa-Wootters, o teorema HJW in breve. Iniziamo con l'enunciato
del teorema, e questa è una versione leggermente semplificata per evitare alcune questioni tecniche e concentrarci sulle idee principali.
Supponiamo che X e Y siano sistemi e che φ sia un qualsiasi vettore di stato quantistico che rappresenta uno stato puro della coppia
XY. Supponiamo ora che consideriamo lo stato ridotto del solo sistema X e che troviamo un qualsiasi modo di
esprimere questo stato ridotto come combinazione convessa di stati puri, come mostrato sullo schermo.
Per esempio, il numero N maiuscolo in questa espressione, che è il numero di stati puri su cui facciamo la media, potrebbe
essere arbitrariamente grande, possibilmente molto più grande della dimensione dello spazio corrispondente a X o a Y.
E ciò che il teorema ci dice è che deve esistere una misurazione sul sistema Y con N risultati tale che
accada quanto segue: quando il sistema Y viene misurato, in primo luogo ogni risultato di misurazione
appare con probabilità esattamente uguale alla probabilità corrispondente nella nostra espressione dello stato ridotto di X come
combinazione convessa di stati puri e, in secondo luogo, condizionato sull'ottenimento di un particolare risultato di misurazione,
lo stato di X diventa il corrispondente stato puro dalla combinazione convessa. Quindi perché è
interessante? Beh, significa che per qualsiasi modo in cui scegliamo di pensare allo stato ridotto di X come combinazione
convessa di stati puri, esiste una qualche misurazione di Y che rende effettivamente reale questo modo di pensare allo stato ridotto di X.
E ciò che è notevole è che questo è possibile anche quando lo stato φ viene scelto prima e la combinazione convessa
viene scelta dopo: finché è un'espressione dello stato ridotto di X, ci sarà una
misurazione di Y che funziona esattamente così. Quindi vediamo come possiamo dimostrarlo.
Iniziamo con due diverse espressioni per lo stato ridotto di X, a cui daremo il nome ρ per
comodità. Poi introduciamo un nuovo sistema Z i cui stati classici sono i possibili risultati di misurazione, o
equivalentemente gli indici nella nostra combinazione convessa. Ora possiamo osservare che i seguenti due vettori di stato quantistico
Γ₀ e Γ₁, che sono entrambi vettori di stato per il sistema composto XYZ,
sono entrambi purificazioni di ρ. E solo per essere chiari, quando pensiamo a questi vettori come purificazioni di ρ, stiamo
pensando ai sistemi Y e Z insieme come a un unico sistema composto che viene tracciato via per lasciare
ρ. Il primo vettore Γ₀ è essenzialmente la stessa cosa dello stato puro originale φ, tranne che stiamo
inizializzando il nuovo sistema Z allo stato zero. È chiaro che se tracciamo via Y e Z, resterà ρ, quindi Γ₀
è una purificazione di ρ. Il secondo vettore Γ₁ è fondamentalmente il vettore che otteniamo purificando
ρ sulla base della combinazione convessa, proprio come ho descritto prima nella lezione. Questa volta il sistema Y è
inizializzato e assumo, per semplicità, che zero sia uno stato classico di Y, ma potresti sostituire qualsiasi
stato della base standard, o in effetti qualsiasi stato puro di Y, in questa espressione e non farebbe alcuna differenza. In ogni caso, tracciando via Y e
Z di nuovo si ottiene ρ, quindi la conclusione è che queste sono entrambe purificazioni di ρ, e quindi per
l'equivalenza unitaria delle purificazioni esiste un'operazione unitaria U sulla coppia YZ che trasforma Γ₀ in
Γ₁. Ed è tutto ciò di cui abbiamo bisogno per fornire una descrizione di una misurazione che fa ciò che il teorema
afferma. Un modo semplice per descriverla è con un diagramma a circuit come quello mostrato qui sullo schermo. In parole, partiamo dallo
stato φ, introduciamo Z inizializzato allo stato zero, eseguiamo U e poi misuriamo il sistema superiore, che è Z, con una
misurazione nella base standard. In sostanza, questo trasforma φ in Γ₁ e,
semplicemente esaminando la descrizione di Γ₁, possiamo vedere che fa ciò che il teorema afferma, ovvero che otteniamo
ogni risultato a con probabilità pₐ e, condizionato sull'ottenimento di a, il sistema X viene lasciato nello stato ψₐ.
E solo per essere chiari, la misurazione stessa di cui il teorema implica l'esistenza è implementata da
tutto ciò che si trova nel rettangolo tratteggiato nella figura. E se vuoi sapere come
la misurazione può essere descritta come una collezione di matrici, ecco un'espressione di esse. Non spiegherò questa parte, e non è
davvero importante per il nostro scopo, ma è un'espressione delle matrici di misurazione nel caso fossi
interessato. Parliamo ora della fedeltà, che è una misura di quanto siano simili due stati quantistici, o in alternativa di quanto
si sovrappongano. Inizieremo con la definizione, che potrebbe sembrare un po' misteriosa a
prima vista, ma la sveliamo e, entro la fine della discussione, spero di averti convinto che è
in realtà una funzione molto più bella di quanto possa sembrare a prima vista. Ed ecco la
definizione: la fedeltà tra due matrici densità ρ e σ è uguale alla traccia della radice quadrata della
radice quadrata di ρ moltiplicata per σ per la radice quadrata di ρ. Ragioniamo
su questo. Prima di tutto, cerchiamo di capire la definizione stessa. Abbiamo tre radici quadrate e
si riferiscono tutte alla radice quadrata di una matrice semidefinita positiva, che come abbiamo discusso nella lezione precedente è
l'unica matrice semidefinita positiva che, elevata al quadrato, ci dà la matrice di cui stiamo estraendo la radice quadrata. Poiché
ρ è una matrice densità, deve essere semidefinita positiva, quindi possiamo estrarne la radice quadrata. Se consideriamo la radice quadrata di ρ moltiplicata per
σ per la radice quadrata di ρ, vediamo che è anche semidefinita positiva, e in particolare possiamo scriverla come
M† × M con M uguale alla radice quadrata di σ per la radice quadrata di ρ, quindi possiamo estrarne la radice
quadrata. In particolare, possiamo calcolare una decomposizione spettrale della radice quadrata di
ρ × σ × radice quadrata di ρ, e poi per estrarne la radice quadrata dobbiamo solo estrarre le radici quadrate degli autovalori
e lasciare gli autovettori invariati. Infine prendiamo la traccia di
questa matrice e, poiché la traccia è uguale alla somma degli autovalori, otteniamo l'espressione che abbiamo
qui. Quindi probabilmente non è qualcosa che vorresti calcolare a mano in generale, e questa spiegazione potrebbe non
fornire molta intuizione sulla fedeltà o sul perché ci interessa, ma si spera che chiarisca il significato tecnico
della formula. Tra l'altro, a margine, a volte le persone definiscono la fedeltà come
il quadrato della funzione che ho definito qui, e chiamano questa funzione radice
fedeltà. La troverai definita in entrambi i modi, il che ha certamente il potenziale di creare confusione, ma di solito non accade
perché le persone sono in genere abbastanza attente nel chiarire quale definizione stiano usando, e anche tu dovresti
fare lo stesso. A mio avviso, non c'è davvero una definizione giusta o sbagliata. La definisco
in questo modo semplicemente perché mi sono abituato a farlo così, e trovo che sia un po' più comoda, credo, perché preferirei elevare al quadrato
qualcosa piuttosto che estrarne la radice quadrata in seguito quando se ne presenta la necessità. Ma naturalmente sei libero di fare la tua
scelta. In ogni caso, torniamo alla fedeltà come definita qui. Esistono altri modi equivalenti di
definire la fedeltà, ed è in realtà una funzione abbastanza notevole sotto questo aspetto, e può essere caratterizzata in modi piuttosto interessanti.
Ecco un modo abbastanza diretto di riscrivere la definizione in termini della norma di traccia, che abbiamo visto verso la
fine della lezione precedente. Non sono entrato troppo nei dettagli sulla norma di traccia e in particolare non l'ho
nemmeno definita per matrici non hermitiane, ma ha una definizione abbastanza semplice. Un modo per definire la norma di traccia di una
di una matrice M arbitraria è la traccia della radice quadrata di M × M dagger, o equivalentemente la traccia della radice
quadrata di M dagger per M: si ottiene lo stesso valore in entrambi i modi, e possiamo usare quella definizione per semplificare la
definizione della fedeltà come abbiamo qui in fondo allo schermo, ed è utile perché rivela che
è simmetrica nei due argomenti. Possiamo anche esprimere la norma di traccia di una matrice quadrata M come il
massimo del valore assoluto della traccia di M × U al variare di tutte le matrici unitarie U, il che non è ovvio, ma è
vero, e questo ci dà un'altra espressione per la fedeltà. Quindi abbiamo qui tre
definizioni equivalenti per la fedeltà, e questo è solo l'inizio: ci sono diverse altre definizioni equivalenti, e
ne vedremo una particolarmente importante, che viene dal teorema di Uhlmann, verso la fine della lezione.
Ok, va bene, ma cosa significa tutto ciò a livello intuitivo, e perché dovrebbe interessarci questa
funzione? Per rispondere a queste domande è utile considerare il caso speciale in cui almeno una delle due matrici densità
rappresenta uno stato puro. Se entrambi gli stati sono puri, allora la
fedeltà è semplicemente il valore assoluto del prodotto interno tra i due vettori di stato quantistico, e in un certo senso
questa è la principale motivazione per la fedeltà stessa: il valore assoluto del prodotto interno tra due vettori di stato quantistico
è sempre un numero compreso tra zero e uno, e ci fornisce un modo naturale di misurare quanto si sovrappongono
due vettori di stato quantistico. Puoi pensare alla fedeltà come a un modo utile e ben definito per
estendere questo modo di misurare la sovrapposizione dagli stati puri alle matrici densità. Se uno degli stati è puro
e l'altro non è necessariamente puro, allora abbiamo di nuovo una semplice espressione per la fedeltà, che può essere molto
comoda, e quell'espressione è mostrata proprio qui. La fedeltà ha molte interessanti
proprietà, ed è uno dei motivi per cui le persone la utilizzano. Ha una definizione che non è davvero
così bella, ma è comunque una funzione molto utile, ed è spesso molto facile da usare, in parte grazie alle sue numerose
straordinarie proprietà. Diamo quindi un'occhiata ad alcune di esse, partendo dall'osservazione che la fedeltà tra due matrici densità
è sempre un numero compreso tra 0 e 1. È zero se e solo se gli stati
sono ortogonali, il che significa che le immagini sono sottospazi ortogonali, o equivalentemente che il prodotto delle due matrici è
zero, e la fedeltà è uno se e solo se le due matrici densità sono uguali. Ogni altro caso si trova da qualche parte
nel mezzo, ma in modo intuitivo, più la fedeltà è vicina a uno, più gli stati sono simili, o in alternativa
più si sovrappongono. La fedeltà è anche simmetrica; l'ho menzionato poco fa, ed è
abbastanza chiaro dall'espressione che abbiamo visto per la fedeltà in termini di norma di traccia, ma è comunque una cosa importante da riconoscere.
Successivamente, la fedeltà è moltiplicativa per gli stati prodotto, il che significa che la fedeltà tra due
stati prodotto è sempre uguale al prodotto delle fedeltà tra i singoli
stati. Ecco una proprietà davvero utile: se abbiamo due qualsiasi matrici densità della stessa dimensione
insieme a qualsiasi canale che prenda queste matrici densità come input, la fedeltà può solo aumentare quando quel canale
viene applicato a entrambi gli stati. In altre parole, in termini di fedeltà, i canali possono solo rendere gli stati
più simili tra loro, non possono renderli meno simili. E infine, per questa lista almeno,
esiste una stretta relazione tra la fedeltà e la distanza di traccia tra gli stati, che è definita
come la metà della norma di traccia della differenza tra le due matrici densità. La distanza di traccia tra due
stati si collega strettamente a quanto bene possiamo distinguerli, come abbiamo discusso nella lezione precedente nel contesto della
discriminazione degli stati e del teorema di Helstrom-Holevo, mentre la fedeltà quantifica quanto si sovrappongono due stati.
Quindi, anche se non sono esattamente la stessa cosa, non sorprende che esista una relazione tra queste
due quantità. In ogni caso, queste disuguaglianze, tipicamente chiamate disuguaglianze di Fuchs–van de Graaf, rendono
questa relazione matematicamente precisa, ed è piuttosto importante che qui non ci sia assolutamente alcuna dipendenza dalla dimensione del sistema di cui stiamo parlando.
Possiamo vedere questa relazione un po' più chiaramente con l'aiuto di una figura. Se abbiamo due stati e
posizioniamo la distanza di traccia tra loro sull'asse x e la fedeltà sull'asse y, allora le corrispondenti linee verticali
e orizzontali devono intersecarsi da qualche parte all'interno di questa regione grigia. La regione più interessante
del grafico, almeno dal punto di vista pratico, è l'angolo in alto a sinistra della regione grigia; in particolare, quando la
distanza di traccia è molto piccola, la fedeltà deve essere molto vicina a uno, e viceversa.
Queste disuguaglianze vengono usate molto frequentemente, e in parte perché spesso ci interessa di più
la distanza di traccia in definitiva, perché ha un'interpretazione naturale che si collega alla discriminazione degli stati quantistici.
Ma la fedeltà ha così tante straordinarie proprietà che in genere è quella più facile con cui lavorare, e finché ci troviamo nell'angolo in alto a sinistra
della regione grigia, che è spesso dove ci troviamo, non perdiamo molto passando avanti e indietro tra la fedeltà e la distanza di traccia. Quindi queste
sono alcune delle proprietà della fedeltà; ce ne sono molte altre, ma è un buon inizio, e speriamo che l'elenco sia
utile per iniziare a sviluppare un po' di intuizione sulla fedeltà. Ecco un bel esempio di come
possiamo collegare la fedeltà alle misurazioni non distruttive. È un fatto molto comodo noto come il
Lemma della misurazione gentile. Supponi di avere un sistema X, uno stato di X rappresentato da una matrice densità ρ, e una misurazione sul sistema X
descritta da una collezione di matrici semidefinite positive. Supponiamo che uno dei risultati di misurazione sia molto probabile
se dovessimo eseguire la misurazione sullo stato ρ. Per semplicità, supponiamo
che sia il risultato zero quello molto probabile, e in particolare assumiamo che questo risultato appaia con
probabilità maggiore di 1 meno epsilon, per qualche piccolo valore di epsilon che non abbiamo bisogno di specificare. Epsilon
è solo un piccolo numero reale positivo. Ora abbiamo descritto la nostra misurazione come se fosse una misurazione distruttiva,
ma sappiamo dalla lezione precedente che potremmo implementarla in modo non distruttivo, e nello specifico potremmo farlo come
abbiamo visto nella nostra discussione del teorema di Naimark, e funziona così: ogni risultato a appare con
probabilità uguale alla traccia di Pₐ × ρ, e condizionato sull'ottenimento di quel risultato lo stato di X cambia in
modo particolare: nel caso in cui otteniamo il risultato probabile zero, lo stato diventa la radice quadrata di P₀ × ρ × la radice quadrata di P₀,
il tutto normalizzato in modo da ottenere una matrice densità. E ciò che il Lemma della misurazione gentile ci dice è che, in questo evento,
cioè che otteniamo effettivamente il risultato di misurazione probabile, lo stato che otteniamo non si sarà modificato di molto rispetto allo
stato originale, e in particolare la fedeltà al quadrato sarà necessariamente maggiore di 1 meno
epsilon. Questo è ottimo perché è completamente generale: non abbiamo detto nulla sulla misurazione o
sullo stato, tranne che uno dei risultati è molto probabile. Quindi il Lemma può essere applicato in
molti contesti diversi in cui vorremmo verificare qualcosa su uno stato quantistico senza perturbarlo troppo. Vediamo quindi come possiamo dimostrarlo:
per la maggior parte si tratta in realtà di una questione abbastanza semplice di calcolare la fedeltà tra gli stati prima e dopo la misurazione.
Possiamo farlo usando la definizione originale, e di solito questo potrebbe lasciarci con una formula complicata, ma
in questo caso siamo fortunati, perché la cosa all'interno della radice quadrata esterna è in realtà il quadrato di una matrice che
risulta essere semidefinita positiva, il che rende banale il calcolo della radice quadrata. Possiamo ora usare la proprietà
ciclica della traccia insieme alla linearità della traccia per semplificare la nostra espressione come mostrato sullo schermo. Nota tra l'altro che queste sono
tutte uguaglianze, quindi non abbiamo approssimato nulla a questo punto, stiamo davvero solo semplificando. Ma ora abbiamo bisogno di una
disuguaglianza, perché vorremmo eliminare quella radice quadrata al numeratore, e possiamo farlo se siamo disposti ad accontentarci di un limite inferiore. E se
ti interessano i dettagli di questa parte, puoi ricavare la disuguaglianza abbastanza facilmente considerando una decomposizione spettrale di P₀.
Gli autovalori di P₀ devono essere compresi tra 0 e 1: questo è sempre vero per le matrici che descrivono
misurazioni. E una volta che lo sappiamo, la disuguaglianza segue abbastanza direttamente dal fatto che estrarre la radice quadrata di
un numero compreso tra 0 e 1 può solo renderlo più grande. Un altro modo per dirlo è che elevare al quadrato un numero compreso tra 0 e
1 può solo renderlo più piccolo. Possiamo ora semplificare ancora un po' e otteniamo la radice
quadrata della traccia di P₀ × ρ. Infine, elevando al quadrato entrambi i membri e
inserendo il nostro limite sulla probabilità, otteniamo ciò che volevamo. Quindi la formula per la fedeltà
non è la più bella o la più facile da usare al mondo, ma qui funziona in modo abbastanza
elegante. Per concludere la lezione, daremo uno sguardo al teorema di Uhlmann, che è un fatto fondamentale sulla fedeltà che
la collega alla nozione di purificazione. Ciò che il teorema afferma in termini semplici è che la fedeltà tra due qualsiasi
stati quantistici è uguale al massimo prodotto interno in valore assoluto tra due purificazioni di quegli
stati. In modo più dettagliato, supponi che ρ e σ siano matrici densità per qualche sistema X, e supponi che Y sia un
sistema che ha almeno tanti stati classici quanti ne ha X, e quindi abbiamo la garanzia che entrambi questi stati abbiano purificazioni che sono
vettori di stato quantistico di XY. Possiamo quindi esprimere l'implicazione del teorema nella forma dell'equazione
mostrata sullo schermo: la fedeltà tra ρ e σ è uguale al massimo valore assoluto del prodotto interno
tra φ e ψ, al variare di tutti i φ e ψ che purificano ρ e σ
rispettivamente. Quindi puliamo questo e lavoriamo con l'enunciato matematico preciso da qui in avanti. Quello che faremo ora è dimostrare
il teorema, ma prima vale la pena fermarsi un momento ad apprezzare che esso ci offre un modo abbastanza intuitivo di pensare alla
fedeltà. È anche piuttosto utile di per sé, ad esempio per dimostrare cose ancora più interessanti sulla
fedeltà. Per dimostrarlo, partiremo dalle decomposizioni spettrali delle nostre matrici densità:
nessuna sorpresa. Una volta che abbiamo le decomposizioni spettrali, è facile trovare
due purificazioni specifiche di questi stati, ma qui useremo in realtà un
trucco. Nota che in entrambi i casi non abbiamo un vettore della base standard come secondo fattore tensoriale, come avevamo prima nella
lezione, bensì lo stesso vettore del primo fattore tensoriale, eccetto che ha una barra sopra di esso, e
ciò significa il coniugato complesso elemento per elemento di questi vettori. In altre parole stiamo sostanzialmente prendendo una
seconda copia degli autovettori, ma ne prendiamo il coniugato complesso di ogni elemento, e vedremo perché lo facciamo tra qualche
momento, ma non è affatto ovvio che dovremmo farlo, ed è per questo che lo chiamiamo un
trucco. In ogni caso, queste sono purificazioni di ρ e σ rispettivamente, e ciò è vero in virtù
del fatto che i nostri autovettori sono ortonormali, e quindi lo sono anche i loro coniugati complessi elemento per elemento. Ora possiamo applicare l'equivalenza
unitaria delle purificazioni, che afferma che ogni purificazione dei nostri due stati può essere ottenuta
applicando un'operazione unitaria al sistema che viene tracciato via. Per le scelte specifiche di purificazioni che
abbiamo appena fatto, le operazioni unitarie non devono essere necessariamente le stesse per le due purificazioni,
naturalmente. Quindi qui usiamo la lettera U per la prima e la lettera V per la seconda.
Quindi il punto è che ogni purificazione dei nostri due stati può essere scritta come abbiamo sullo schermo, per
qualche scelta di operazioni unitarie U e V. E ora possiamo prendere l'espressione
del teorema e semplificarla: se inseriamo le nostre espressioni per φ e ψ e semplifichiamo un po', otteniamo
l'espressione mostrata qui sullo schermo. Ci sono un paio di passaggi lì che non ho mostrato nei dettagli,
quindi sai cosa fare se vuoi verificarlo. Lasciami però menzionare che il motivo per cui abbiamo scelto le purificazioni nel modo in cui le abbiamo scelte
era per permettere a questo prodotto interno di semplificarsi esattamente in questo modo, e in particolare abbiamo messo i coniugati complessi
lì per poter effettivamente invertire i prodotti interni nel secondo fattore tensoriale e ottenere la forma specifica
che abbiamo proprio qui. Ci siamo quasi: ora possiamo usare la proprietà ciclica della traccia insieme
alle decomposizioni spettrali con cui abbiamo iniziato per ottenere questa espressione, e a questo punto possiamo
impiegare uno dei modi alternativi di esprimere la fedeltà usando la norma di traccia, e abbiamo
finito. Ci sono certamente dei dettagli che ho sorvolato molto rapidamente, ed è il tipo di dimostrazione che
devi davvero lavorare da solo per comprenderla appieno, ma speriamo che questo ti dia l'idea di base.
E come al solito puoi trovare maggiori dettagli nel contenuto scritto della lezione, che è linkato nella
descrizione del video. E questa è la fine della lezione, che ha riguardato le purificazioni, la fedeltà e le connessioni tra di esse. È anche
la fine dell'unità, che ha riguardato la formulazione generale dell'informazione quantistica. Spero che ti unirai a me per
la quarta e ultima unità della serie, che riguarda la correzione degli errori quantistici. Grazie per aver guardato.